president Trump's decision to withdraw
from the Iranian nuclear deal in
imposing tough new sanctions on Iran
instead the president gives some
companies up to six months to wind down
involvement with Iran when the United
States violated the Iranian nuclear deal
it didn't happen in a vacuum it was
actually the result of a lobbying
campaign backed by some of the richest
people in the u.s. these are people that
have really extreme views when it comes
to Iran and there's ample evidence that
they are willing to use their money to
further their anti Iran views when
President Trump withdrew the u.s. from
the historic Iran nuclear deal in May
2018 he actually ended years of
diplomatic efforts that reset the u.s.
Iran relationship which prior to that
had been non-existent since Iran's 1979
revolution
it also unraveled one of the Obama
administration's signature foreign
policy achievements and when against the
US as European allies the collapse of
the Iran deal is a catastrophic missed
opportunity for diplomacy I think that
that this decision is going to be viewed
similar to the decision to invade Iraq
in 2003 so how exactly did this happen
hi guys I'm Omar and this Sunday we're
talking about how major lobbying efforts
orchestrated by corporate billionaires
led to the USS violation of the Iran
nuclear deal
[Music]
okay before we get into the why where
and how let's make sure we got the
basics down in 2015 you're on reached an
agreement on its nuclear program with
the p5 plus one otherwise known as the
US Russia France the UK China and
Germany the agreements severely
restricted Iran's ability to enrich
uranium it also ensured for the first
time that Iran would not seek a nuclear
weapon something it had already once
pledged to do it's a historic agreement
involving the u.s. Iran and other world
powers in which sanctions were exchanged
for caps on Iran's nuclear program and
strict inspections to verify that Iran
was not moving towards the nuclear
weapons capability but behind the scenes
there was a furious dash of lobbying
involving nearly a hundred and fifty
million dollars in a large group of
organizations working non-stop to kill
the deal in Congress but who exactly
were these groups we spoke to Eli
Clifton who is reported extensively on
them and their activities a unifying
message that seemed to be coming out of
groups opposing the Iran deal was a
series of talking points talking about
Iran's hegemonic ambitions in the region
and threat to US regional allies like
Saudi Arabia UAE and Israel at the
forefront of the fight was a pact or the
American Israel Public Affairs Committee
it aggressively advocated that the deal
was a bad idea
that would hurt Israel and US interests
AIPAC spent approximately thirty million
dollars on their campaign through a
subsidiary group known as Citizens for a
nuclear-free Iran this included
political ads on TV flying in a pack
members to DC to lobby members of
Congress and organizing demonstrations
check out this ad by citizens for a
nuclear-free Iran Iran is
violated 20 international agreements and
is the leading state sponsor of
terrorism AIPAC incidentally didn't
originally want to be involved in this
policy battle but was pushed into it by
their backers and funders and ended up
very much giving voice to Israeli
concerns possibly at the expense of a
discussion about American interests in
the region but AIPAC wasn't alone the
Republican Jewish coalition foundation
for the defense of democracies united
against nuclear Iran and the Israeli
American Council all opposed the
agreement altogether
opposition groups were 5 times better
funded than their opponents supporting
the deal the groups opposing the nuclear
deal went into this with an enormous
financial advantage all of them were
pre-existing in Washington all of them
were well-funded
by Republicans and in case of AIPAC
Republican and Democrat donors back in
2015 Jamal Abdi was working with the
National Iranian American Council to
make the Iran deal a reality as we were
advocating for this we knew the other
side was pushing back hard and they
weren't going anywhere
you know they lost because the White
House was able to pull this off and we
were able to help put enough pressure on
Congress that they didn't kill the deal
if you're wondering where this windfall
of anti deal money and support for anti
deal groups came from the answer is
billionaires and Sheldon Adelson tops
the list of names funding these groups
Adelson has been at the forefront of
financially supporting Republican causes
and pro-israel initiatives for decades
Sheldon Adelson and his wife Miriam are
the Republican Party's biggest donors
they were also Donald Trump's single
that largest backers in his campaign
efforts in 2016 that's something we
often forget the Las Vegas billionaire
even said that an atomic weapon should
be fired at Iran so there's an atomic
weapon goes over a ballistic missiles
admitted that the middle of the desert
that doesn't hurt a soul maybe a couple
of rattlesnakes and scorpions or
whatever and then and then you say see
the next one is in the middle of Tahrir
Adelson has contributed millions of
dollars to groups lobbying against Iran
deal this includes half a million
dollars to united against nuclear Iran
one and a half million dollars to the
foundation for the defense of
democracies and ten million dollars to
the Israeli American Council he also
happens to be a board member of the
Republican Jewish coalition and likely
its largest finds here according to you
like Clifton the RJ C's 2012
contributions showed one large donation
of over five million dollars from an
unnamed donor beyond a tellson there's
also Home Depot co-founder Bernard
Marcus who's also donated millions to
anti-iran groups listen to what he says
about Iran in this 2015 interview you
when you do business with the devil
you're in deep trouble and I think that
Iran is the devil Marcus gave more than
ten million to the hawkish foundation
for defense of democracies or FTD
between 2008 and 2011 and over three
million dollars in 2015 and AIPAC which
we told you about earlier he's given
millions to them as well there's one
more donor you should know about Paul
singer is a hedge fund billionaire who
donated over a three and a half million
dollars to the FTD in 2011 and one and a
half million dollars to AIPAC between
2010 and 2011 but despite the best
efforts and deep pockets of the anti
Iran deal lobbyists they were unable to
defeat the Iran deal in Congress in 2015
so in 2016 the Coalition and their
billionaire backers tried a different
approach Donald J Trump never ever ever
in my life have I seen any transaction
so incompetently negotiated as our deal
with Iran but we knew that once a new
president came in once the circumstances
changed there was going to be all this
money sort of on the table in place to
try to kill the deal and if not kill the
deal at least contain it Adelson Marcos
and singer spent a lot of money to help
elect Donald Trump combined they donated
40 million dollars to pro-trump
political groups they also worked in
sure he'd have a strong Congress to
support him by spending 65 million
dollars back in Republican candidates in
the House and Senate so when you have
three billionaires who pride
oriT eyes based off of their public
private as well as their philanthropic
efforts and comments opposing the
nuclear deal and the United States
pursuing a hawkish policy it's series of
policies in the Middle East it's hard to
imagine that any Republican candidate
doesn't listen very carefully to what
these individuals have to say
fast forward to early 2018 Trump is
president and hasn't yet reneged on the
Iran deal as he pledged during his
campaign he'd actually renewed it more
than once but John Bolton Trump's
national security adviser would change
that John Bolton had been george w
bush's ambassador to the UN he was known
as a vocal proponent of the Iraq war and
open advocate of war with Iran and a
longtime critic of the Iran nuclear deal
there's a lot we can do and we should do
it our goal should be regime change in
Iran and according to Politico Trump's
chief of staff John Kelly had cut the
president's interactions with Bolton
prior to him joining the administration
because of his fringe views enter
Sheldon Adelson by multiple accounts
Sheldon Adelson is a big fan of John
Bolton Allison made sure to get Trump to
listen to Bolton and with Bolton back in
Trump's ear his influence on the
president was felt almost instantly just
four weeks after Bolton assumed the role
of national security adviser the u.s.
violated the terms of the Iran deal the
fact is this was a horrible one-sided
deal that should have never ever been
made it didn't bring calm it didn't
bring peace and it never will so money
was a key factor in the campaign against
a diplomatic breakthrough between two
countries that hadn't managed to agree
on anything for decades all these groups
with all these vested interests kept
busy and there they're you know moneyed
interests and constituencies stayed
active and they ended up winning in the
end but where do the United States and
Iran go from here
well Iran is seeking to keep the deal
alive between itself and European powers
without the United States and if that
were to fail can we expect a huge
influence of anti Iran groups in the
u.s. to lead us to war there's a real
opportunity for the United States in
Iran to wind up in
a direct heated conflict with one
another we're gonna need to have more
hearings and more public awareness of
the risk of that war and create legal
and political barriers to an eventual
war and the means to escalate to that
war so what do you guys think
were you guys aware that corporate
billionaires have basically demolished
the Iran deal let us know in the
comments about other stories that you'd
like us to report on and don't forget to
Like share and subscribe